this video is brought to you by Dragon
City what's up wisecrack michael here
what's the deal with comedians
delivering the news are they comedians
or reporters pick a length in all
seriousness if you've consumed any of
the horrible news lately there's a good
chance at least some of it came from
comedians like trevor noah john oliver
samantha bee or hasan minhaj with a host
promising to make their comedy more
informative and politically engaged it
seems like they're intentionally
pitching themselves as an alternative to
cable news and while Trevor Noah and
Samantha beam might be more entertaining
than Chris Wallace original Matthau we
can't help but wonder is comedy news a
brilliant symbiosis of the comedic and
the political or is it just a kind of
mental junk food that occasionally makes
us snicker she came off to him again
tonight I bet when he got in his car
lady she just popped up in the backseat
like oh and another thing let's find out
in this wisecrack edition comedy news
deep or dumb before we get into it I
want to give a shout out to Dragon City
a mobile RPG available on iOS and
Android Dragon city is like a hero
collector but instead of heroes you
collect dragons generate goal to buy
food and level up your dragons for
battle there are hundreds of dragons
hidden in Dragon city for you to collect
I recently found the binge dragon the
movement addict dragon and the serial
killer dragon you want to collect as
many dragons as you can but it's also
possible to breed different dragon
species to complete your collection here
I bread my Vinge dragon with the movie
fanatic dragon and they had the neon
track collect as many dragons as you can
and use them to battle download the game
for free is in the link in the
description now back to the show first a
bit of history on comedy news shows much
like the career of John Oliver modern
comedy news was born in England before
finding success in America the germinal
versions of the comedy news format can
be seen in the work of frequent
collaborators Armando Iannucci and Chris
Morris two British political satirist
who collectively were behind shows like
a veep and the thick of it as well as
movies like for lions and the day shall
come their first TV show the day today
aired in 1994 and offered a satirical
take on British news while it brought up
current events the show had no intention
of being informative and instead focused
on the absurdity of news media Morris's
next show brass I was in even more
intense Saturdays Asian of the
sensational tone of Current Affair shows
- your 26,000 pounds but I'm watching
you from a balloon and I can see a very
long way I go along with that one of its
most infamous episodes was the PETA get
in special which explored the moral
panic and hysteria around pedophiles in
the sexualization of children media
Jezz north is released tomorrow can we
be sure that pervert mechanics haven't
built him one of these of course we
can't the episode immediately led to
over 3000 complaints and criticism from
government officials while the work of
the annucci amorous novel standard for
using the news format to create comedy
magic their aimless satirizing society
and the media not providing actual news
or information this was the basic ethos
of even the original Daily Show hosted
by Craig Kilborn
which focused on covering oddball
stories and offered comedic takes on
historic events getting everyone
together getting everything to work out
and laughter turns to tears
it also included lots of field pieces
which according to former anchor Steve
Carell were a little too mean in
hindsight but no one was watching the
first iteration of The Daily Show in
hopes of getting their daily dose of
news this all changed when Jon Stewart
took over the show in 1999 under
Stewart's reign the show became
significantly more news driven this
shift was put into sharp focus by their
coverage of the 2000 election and
politics after 9/11 by 2009 a Time
magazine poll showed that Stewart had
become the most trusted news anchor on
the air
Stewart even effectively shamed real
news show CNN's crossfire out of
existence by appearing as a guest and
roasting its hosts for their
sensationalism and partisan hackery your
partisan what'd he call it hacks
thanks to Stewart The Daily Show was so
influential that basically every single
comedy news show right now is hosted by
its alumni including John Oliver
Samantha B Hasan Minhaj and Wyatt Cenac
and then there's Stephen Colbert who
used his Daily Show spin-off as a
stepping-stone to eventually become the
host of CBS's The Late Show
history aside is this modern format deep
or dumb
does this injection of comedy make for
an even better method of asking
questions and informing the audience too
that out we're gonna get some help from
comedy theorist Todd McGowan and his
book only a joke can save us for McGowan
comedy happens how we were surprised by
a moment where lack and excess meat but
simply a moment where something that
seemed insignificant is treated with
excessive importance or a moment where
something very significant is treated
with a lacking indifference and
sometimes these moments not only make us
laugh they help us to rethink the world
around us but let's start with the
meeting of excess and lack while this
sounds a little heady McGowan uses the
example of the Black Knight and Monty
Python's Holy Grail and which the knight
loses all four limbs in a sword fight
but refuses to give up claiming that
each subsequent severed limb is just the
lack in this example is quite literally
the Black Knights missing limbs the
excess is the absurd confidence he
continues to exhibit as he dies it's the
bringing together of two disparate
elements brutal violence and reckless
confidence that creates this comedic
moment it's the same reason that it's
funny when Michael Scott burns his foot
on a George Foreman grill in the office
which is a dumb household injury and
then insist on sneaking his foot inside
of an x-ray machine if he had the same
injury but treated it like it wasn't a
big deal
that wouldn't be comedic if he had a
serious injury and treated it seriously
also not funny but a non serious injury
treated with absurd seriousness does the
trick well using a philosophical formula
to evaluate comedy seems about as fun as
bringing a dietitian with you to Taco
Bell it can help us see what the
funniest comedy news shows have in
common and make sense of when jokes fall
flat so let's look at the origin of the
modern comedy news wave in America the
original Daily Show many of the earliest
segments on the show involve
correspondents like Stephen Colbert and
Steve Carell going out and interviewing
small-town politicians or oddballs with
the journalistic intensity of reporting
on war crimes but most modern comedy
news has shifted away from field
reporting and absurdist characters
towards talking head style monologues
for example in this recent segment from
full frontal as Samantha bee she talks
about the very serious issue of
reopening in America in light of the
COBIT 19 pandemic and while there are
some genuinely funny zingers called on
people to liberate Minnesota Michigan
and Virginia man the Franklin Mint chess
sets from this new civil war are gotta
be ugly
she mostly talks about the dire
seriousness of the situation so we have
an excessive response to an excessive
situation one might themselves not along
and agree with be in this segment but
you're probably not unexpectedly
chuckling and sure not everything needs
to be funny or funny as McGowan defines
it but there is another kind of pitfall
to this style of comedy news it lacks
what McGowan argues makes comedy
politically potent in the first place
which helps get us into the relationship
between comedy and political news the
gallon thinks that there is an inherent
connection between comedy and politics
writing comedy has the potential to act
as a site for radical emancipatory
politics but it can just as easily
function in the most ideological fashion
and the guise of radicality in other
words comedy can be a magic pill that
helps open our eyes to what's really
going on or it can simply reaffirm the
status quo and help us see
contradictions in our world or pacify us
into content Lee chuckling about nobody
taking away grandpa's keys jokes can
make us question our world in ourselves
or jokes can just affirm what we already
know and that's why when Trevor Noah
talks about the impeachment trial in The
Daily Show
there aren't any truly surprising
comedic moments as it's assumed that
most of the audience already agrees with
a particular point of view being
expressed the jokes aren't pointing out
any instances of lack or contradictions
either and Noah himself or with the
audience
instead all lack and critique is on one
side of course this isn't universally
true for Noah or any of these shows
later in the same segment correspondent
Michael Kosta does some reporting from
the field which places some critical
lack on the side of Democrats joyously
celebrating Trump's impeachment but it's
more or less a softball criticism
downright depressing yeah Nancy today
sucked comedy like this usually doesn't
challenge preconceptions it simply
affirms them this is what McGowan writes
that comedy has the ability to deprive
us of our safety net and this is why
recognizing what's at stake in comedy
has the status of an ethical imperative
comedy is related to ethics because it
can distance us from our comfortable
worldview and challenges to notice the
contradictions and our own ideals we can
see a comedy news show that functions
like this and the work of yet another
Daily Show alum Hasan Minhaj and his
show Patriot Act unlike the nightly news
format used by The Daily Show and
full-frontal Patriot Act uses the format
of an investigative journalism show to
deep dive into a
cific topic with each episode Emma now
sees particular format often achieves
what McGowan calls egalitarian comedy
which is when both the source of the
comedy and its target appear divided
internally it is the emergence of this
internal division that enables us to
laugh while also facilitating critique
for example in the episode about Amazon
Minaj doesn't just talk about how Amazon
is ethically dubious while we not along
in the knowledge that we also have the
correct opinion instead the episode
points out that we are complicit in some
of the things that are bad about this
company by participating in it so the
source of the comedy Minaj and the
target Amazon both juxtaposes the
excessive wealth of Amazon and the lack
of Ethical Treatment of its employees
and our own excessive knowledge of these
wrongdoings with our own lack of
commitment to doing anything about it
unlike Facebook and Google who need your
customer data to sell ads to businesses
Amazon is a one-stop shop and they know
who you are what you buy and will sell
it directly to you despite knowing all
of this I'm not gonna lie I'm still
gonna use Amazon it's an essential
utility for me
so for comedy used to work as a source
of news and information it has to be
capable of evaluating all sides of an
issue or story even if that means making
visible the contradictions shared by the
host and audience this is why comedy
news shows often work best when they
swing both ways which isn't to say that
these shows are sexually open but rather
that they use comedies that critically
consider both ends of the political
spectrum even if doing so challenges the
audience's assumptions this was a
particular strength of stewards tenure
on the Daily Show well Stewart was
firmly situated on the Left he had no
qualms about roasting his own camp
without that ethos we end up in the
danger zone actor where rather than
responding to jokes with laughter we
clap along to affirm that we also agree
with the right ideas when a comedy news
show veers too far into clap tur we end
up with what McGowan calls conservative
comedy which doesn't refer to
conservative political parties but
rather to comedy that aims to affirm
ideologies rather than challenge them we
can see this in the previously mentioned
full-frontal segment where Samantha bee
affirms one point of view that implies
the exclusion of another this style of
comedy news locates all of the lack or
ridicule on a particular external group
or authority and locates the excess of
goodness on the side of its host
it might criticize authority but it
leaves the viewer and host unscathed and
of course this criticism goes beyond
laughter but cuz McGowan thinks that
comedy has an inherently philosophical
structure any news source aiming to
really seek out the truth would have to
operate with the same commitment to
locating the lack in the social order
and while studies and surveys have long
shown that many young people consider
comedy news shows as their primary news
source other studies have shown that
these people might have good reason to
do this researchers at the University of
Delaware actually found that regular
viewers of satirical news were better
informed than regular viewers of cable
news and it's not too surprising that
the most informed of these viewers were
those regularly watching last week
tonight with John Oliver the show has
become known for wide-ranging critiques
of powerful people and institutions and
his ability to inspire social change has
led to multiple news sources writing
about the John Oliver effect this effect
has led to massive campaigns against the
tobacco industry televangelist and the
coal mining industry so it seems like at
its best comedy news is capable of the
type of humorous reporting that can lead
to social change by criticizing both
those in power and its audience but at
its worst it offers the sort of in-group
logic that creates more thoughtful nods
than it does gut-busting laughs while
some like The Daily Show with Trevor
Noah and full-frontal might lean towards
the latter category shows like last week
tonight and Patriot Act have veered
towards the former this all leads us
back to our initial question is comedy
news deep or dumb it seems that rather
than falling simply on one side of this
dichotomy that comedy news is both deep
and dumb sorry it's deep one it
challenges our preconceived notions and
dumb when it leads to self-satisfied
Clapton and each show probably has
genuine moments of both but what do you
think wisecrack is comedy news a
valuable source of both laughs and
information or is it just a low-stakes
way to relax by chuckling at the news
let us know what you think in the
comments and before you go I want to
give one last shout out to Dragon City
once you have a collection of dragons
you can take them to battle and collect
gold and exp use food to level your
dragons and after some training they
should be ready to win some battles the
game offers different PvP modes where
you can take your favorite dragons and
fight in the leagues or in the arena
there are new events every week like
match 3 puzzles and mazes start growing
your dragon collection and go to battle
today hit the link in the description to
download the game for free
and as always thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]